deuxième titre de l'actualité deux
lieutenants d'al qaïda ont été capturés
cette semaine au pakistan la d'entre eux
serait l'un des cerveaux l'un des
organisateurs des attentats du 11
septembre
ce coup de filet s'est déroulée à
karachi mercredi dernier jour
anniversaire des attentats
bertrand cocq
la police pakistanaise pour la puissance
de feu le fbi et la cia pour le
renseignement à l'arrivée cette
arrestation dont l'une des figures d'al
qaïda c'était mercredi dernier à karachi
au pakistan
à l'origine de cette opération un coup
de fil passé avec un téléphone
satellitaire et capté par les services
secrets américains
parmi les personnes arrêtées figure un
saoudien et égyptien des yéménites
tous membres d'al-qaïda selon les
pakistanais mais surtout ramzi
binalshibh sur la liste des personnes
les plus recherchées depuis un an et
soupçonnés d'avoir directement participé
à la planification des attentats de l'an
dernier avant le 11-septembre binalshibh
avait séjourné ici à hambourg en
allemagne dans l'appartement de mohammed
atta le chef du commando suicide
et il aurait sans doute fait parti des
pirates de l'air si les américains ne
lui avait pas refusé à quatre reprises
le visa d'entrée aux états unis une
première opération mardi avait déjà
permis l'interpellation de trois hommes
tous ces suspects sont interrogés à la
fois par les pakistanais et les
amériques
nous traquons les assassins un parent
s'est félicité de george bush nous
sommes un pitoyable nous sommes forts et
nous n'allons pas nous arrêter a dit
encore le président américain sans
préciser que ces arrestations
constituent le premier succès tangibles
depuis des mois dans la lutte contre
l'organisation d'oussama ben laden